RAJAT KHANNA: As one of the
largest home improvement
retailers, our strategy
really revolves
around winning the customer and
better competing for the pro
by enabling both customer
segments to make homes better
for all from inspiration
to installation.
We want our customers to have
the best experience with us,
regardless of how, when, or
where they choose to shop.
For our dev ops,
look, our philosophy
is really an approach
to software development
that enables teams to build,
test, and release software
faster and more reliably.
VIVEK BALIVADA: Did we
uncover anything surprising?
Yes.
So our 300x increase
in release velocity
and GCP ability to support the
scaling was an added value.
The power and potential of GCP
and our Google SI principles
enabled us to achieve a
lot of this automation very
seamlessly.
And we were able to focus on
reliability and technology.
An example of this includes
collaborating and strategizing,
the change request automation
process with IP service
management and optimizing our
regression and performance test
suites.
RAJAT KHANNA: And at the core
of our dev ops ecosystem,
we have four
principles we follow,
ownership and accountability.
What that really
means is our teams
are fully committed
from birth of an idea
to the product's launch.
Systems thinking, performance of
the entire technology ecosystem
takes precedence
over the performance
of a specific theme.
Continuous experimentation
and learning and automation.
VIVEK BALIVADA: It's
an awesome experience,
you know, all the partnership,
the weekly calls that we
have with the Google team.
RAJAT KHANNA: So with our
dev ops transformation
to Google Cloud, we've gone
from doing 30 releases to more
than 4,500 releases per year.
Look, what this means is
going from one release
every two weeks to
more than 20 releases
daily, a massive improvement.
VIVEK BALIVADA: I'm so
excited to win this award.
And it showcases our
team's journey, right,
how we continue to power our
dev ops and SI principles.
RAJAT KHANNA: This award is
a recognition for both Google
and Lowe's.
[MUSIC PLAYING]